let's see if this works
we are live again
uh i guess i can watch it on my own to
see if
the issues are are there
where you at youtube stream here
sounds great to me
where you at youtube stream had a car in
the background but
no it sounds perfect to me i guess i
just need to restart obs for some reason
that's [ __ ] weird all right
that doesn't make any sense
i literally just restarted obs i didn't
change a single setting
uh do we have twitch back it looks like
twitch isn't working
twitch
i am here twitch is working
oh it does say the video download was
canceled oh it's maybe not just because
i stopped streaming
how odd
is it just going to catch up what the
[ __ ] does this mean
is people on twitch can you not hear me
at all
because it says to me the download was
canceled please try again whatever that
means
thank you scott 22.
um try twitch again
that's so weird why is it black on
twitch but perfectly fine on everything
else
that doesn't make any sense
is there some kind of like twitch
setting that i need to change because
this whole stream was meant to be to be
like thank you for having uh 30 000
followers on twitch
why would it not be working i've never
seen this before
let's try and google this issue the
video download was canceled please try
again
twitch error
yep
it's so weird i've never seen this
before okay
um
delete twitch cookies you say
okay you can give that a shot
wait but then everyone would have to
delete their twitch cookies right
yeah the audio being fixed is great even
though again i didn't [ __ ] do
anything i just turned it on and off
again
i did also just do a fun house video
right before this i hope that doesn't
have
crappy audio that i have to redo but i
guess we'll find out
um i have no idea what this problem is
twitch
i don't know what's happening
let me try and turn is it maybe that
like am i
outputting too much is that because i'm
trying to do 10 000 is that too high
like is that a thing that can happen
maybe
uh downey miller it was just a open
house
my favorite male cologne oh man it's
like it's it's like billion or something
it's gold whatever it is love the smell
of it
i already did turn it on and off again
tommy i already did
do you think that i should make the
twitch stream i'll just explain to you
what the gameplay looks like
and i guess what i look like
make a pc build video yeah all that
money i have
my bit rate is 10 000.
it's very high
um
uh no inferior meat i'm going to try to
fix twitch
but i have no [ __ ] idea how to fix
this issue
i love other it tells me there are 32
people of you watching this disaster 90
apparently
i'm watching my yeah my bit rate right
now is 10 388 that's that's just high
lower it i don't know if that will work
um
can i do that live will that work live i
just tried let's see if that actually
does anything
it should have okay it's down to eight
thousand
still nothing twitch still nothing
um i mean to be fair jason
my streams are always in troubleshooting
to begin with
yeah nils it's working on on facebook
it's working on mixer it's working on
youtube it's just not working on twitch
which is really strange
no idea why that would be happening
twitch specifies max bitrate okay let's
take my
my bit rate down to because it's still
over six thousand let's take it down to
four thousand that kind of sucks though
but all right let's do it see what
happens
bit rate is down
i get that you could all go to youtube
but i don't want to do that because part
of why i wanted to stream today was to
say thank you for
everyone thank you to everyone for
following me on twitch
okay bitrate is definitely below 6000
now let's try turning twitch off
and then on again
let's see what happens okay
should be back on
wow this is so [ __ ] strange
um it's back on i think
no um oh it worked
i think it worked i think we got it
it looks like it's working yes i just
pressed
on and off and it worked
they weren't lying on and off a success
how ridiculous i guess my bet rate was
too high which that really sucks that's
a really shitty thing for twitch to do i
didn't know
they did that but i guess they do
thank you ross your character was
basically a combination of easy pete and
elizabeth comstock based on the inside
joke of an easy pete expanded universe
i'm playing this game without much of a
character on this save so far i don't
really have a lot
yeah on and off again really did work
twitch generally has less lag than other
services incorrect
mix is the only one that is um 100
no lag faster than light
yeah mixer um got them speeds that's
that's
the only one and it's real good
zebra just said why do people come into
our chat and are calling her gorgeous
or beautiful did your mother's not teach
you any manners treat her with more
respect she's a person not your object
listen i do not find people calling me
beautiful or gorgeous to be in
any way disrespectful if you see someone
and you find them attractive you can
tell them that
but at the same time
i am generally not going to engage with
that very much because i'm much more
interested in talking about
video games or what's happening in the
game
or the technical issues or the real
world or whatever
it's not disrespectful at all i don't
find it offensive when someone says that
stuff
um it's just not an issue but it's also
the same as like if someone calls me
ugly i don't care either like
i put very little weight into my
appearance my one of my favorites is if
people call me ugly and i'm like
how are you going to be a model why
would that
why would i care that that if you think
that why the [ __ ] would that be a
problem it's just not an issue
i don't mind my cam is really big
i mean it's not though it's probably
like the issue you're having is that it
maybe looks like i'm zoomed in i don't
feel like this is very big
it's that the chair is huge but my
actual face is taking up a very small
portion of this screen it's just a
really big chair
i could cut the chair out i guess
yeah it might look like it zoomed in
which is just because there's light on
the green screen that i tried to cut out
but
uh how far am i into the game this is um
probably about four hours maybe um
if even i'm not sure if that would even
be right yeah original [ __ ]
painting the chair green is a good call
i do still have the ultrawide screen i
love it
see what happens if i cut the chair up
because honestly my face is taking up
such a small amount of the screen it's
just that
the webcam in general is taking up a bit
more
because of the chair i could cut part of
it
what is it that's filters add crop
also hey everyone welcome if you aren't
familiar with my streams i tend to start
the first
15 minutes or so with just talking every
time pretty much what is it left that we
want to cut
cut 50. that's just moving me over why
is that moving me over 15
uh 100 200
300 no that's too much 250.
yeah that works and then we'll just
slide ourselves back over but see now
that looks [ __ ]
weird this is what you asked for but it
looks
[ __ ] weird
zebra i agree that i would way prefer
someone engaging it he said sorry as
from youtube
i understand you might not mind but i
see all the time girls in streams like
why not hey hello why do people feel the
need to only focus on looks instead of
the content provided
i generally would prefer that someone
talk about
what i'm playing or whatever then
comment on my appearance which is why i
don't reply to it
um but i don't think it's disrespectful
to tell someone that you find them
attractive i just don't feel like that's
oh there i go um disrespectful is the
thing that i took issue with because i
just don't find that it is you know
but it's not long john liverpool
you support liverpool did you find the
companion abilities
animations a bit tedious in the end i
think that the companions
are a little too aggressive in any case
we've already reached a thousand
messages in chat
how about them xbox reveals today yeah i
made a youtube video about them
oh well thank you for staying up with me
holland and thank you all for 30 000
followers i know that's not very many
compared to a lot of people out there
but i think it's cool so thank you
how is the game oh i mean this game is
old uh
keanus um certainly isn't a new game but
i think it's great i really really like
it
so it's good [ __ ]
thank you jeffy danny i appreciate that
who's my favorite player outside of
liverpool
i like hazard um son
is probably my number one from uh
tottenham
if we could get him
uh patrick i use uh obs to stream
i do stream horror games iclean muse i
think that
most of my streams have actually
probably been horror games like probably
legitimately
most of them macia ronaldo messi
i think this game around ronald will run
well on the switch
yeah i don't know it's like i'm very
curious about this game specifically
um i feel like it will if skyrim can and
witcher can
jm said this game is basically what he
thought or she sorry um
76 thought it could turn into might be
might be right you disliked this game
curious why i think this game's great
would i consider doing a q a section on
the podcast like with viewers writing in
questions
uh if you're talking about play watch
listen um yeah
uh if people ask questions that i think
are relevant to the topic we're talking
about that week i'd be happy to do that
probably not a segment though how do i
keep up with all the chats on the
platforms it's very easy restream which
is the program that i use
to stream to multiple chats uh has a
restream chat function so they're all
actually on the same screen
they're all exactly the same way
yeah i think this game is really good um
but it's also
a pretty pretty excessive rpg what my
thoughts on fallout 4 i couldn't
really get into it i love fallout 3.
it's probably one of my favorite games
ever
um vegas is obviously great but even
then i like fallout 3 more which i know
most people disagree with
stu just keeps asking if i give head um
i should probably add a mod
to to uh
this chat huh let me see if i recognize
any of you
don't chat messages disappear too
quickly i mean they do but i think they
do anyway
like they're hard to keep up with no
matter what really
dark knight said are you a go after
achievement person or just play the game
uh both i will go after achievements if
i think they sound fun and they're going
to add more to the game for me
but i won't go for [ __ ] that i don't
want to do so i do care about
achievements but only if i want them
my mod from mixer is here oh scooterman
gaming yeah i can i can mod you bro how
do i do that though scooterman gaming
mod i know what you have to do both
though but that said makes it generally
doesn't need moderation that's
that is such a nice platform underrated
um as you already probably know
mod don't care if people are mean to me
don't let them be mean to each other but
if someone's mean to me you can leave
that i don't care
uh but if they're spamming the same [ __ ]
you're gonna get rid of that probably
get rid of sexual [ __ ] too because then
the whole chat will be focused on it but
generally
yeah i don't i have a policy that is uh
i don't like getting rid of people just
for criticizing me i think i think
that's
too harsh you know
do i play warzone i have i'm not very
good at it
you can be mean to me it's fine i'm used
to it you know
where was the game play in the xbox
presentation ray uh
i think that we probably saw more
gameplay than we realize
is what i'm going to say
am i going to be a full member on fun
house again look
probably not because it's sort of
impossible the way visas work ladies and
gentlemen
uh for me to even go contract i had to
give my visa to another
company so another company literally
owns my visa now not rooster teeth that
had to work that way
for me to be full house full time at
funhouse again
uh which a i don't think i'm ready to do
yet i don't want to go right back into
being full time and then just make
myself sick all over again it seems like
a bad idea i think that i would want to
wait a year anyway um but rusty
definitely even when i left were like
we're doing with this with the hopes
that you will come back full-time
eventually
maybe so it would have to wait a certain
amount of time if i i just changed my
visa in october if i'm to change my visa
again
right now a can't because of the
pandemic which is why i say it's
unlikely in general
but b um you can't do it too close to
yourself or it looks shady to the
government
so the idea was that maybe i would do it
in a year when i'm ready whatever um but
right now
seems very very very unlikely because of
uh the literal visa process that i am
under is one that i believe has been
kind of shut down applications are shut
down
so unlikely it's good that they're
flexible with me well
they are but also you know i took a
dramatic pay cut i'm like
not making any money they're you they're
they're
not paying me well at all which was like
kind of how it had to have to work so it
was flexible but it certainly benefits
them
too you know it's not just beneficial to
me
no i'm not back in australia i'm in the
us i still work for funhouse it's just
another company who you've probably
never heard of
because this is the way it had to work
for me illegally owns my visa
i did spend a pretty long time
customizing this character you know
dylan and i don't even remember what he
looks like now
that's nuts
oh thank you i appreciate that f-sharp
yeah it's it's a complicated situation
in that um
look i feel like i talk about being ill
too much
and simultaneously undersell it
dramatically so like i talk about it
whenever people ask which is
every time i'm live every q a
and i feel like i've been pretty candid
online about dealing with health issues
and
fainting and you know it's not like i've
hidden away from it at first i didn't
there was a period where i didn't upload
a youtube video for like four months and
people like what happened so i made the
video where it was like i've been really
unwell um
so it's a complicated thing to be like i
don't think i can work full-time
i just don't think i can do it right now
i don't want to risk it
but then i don't want to lose everything
it's it's hot it's hard for my brain to
to deal with in a way that it's like i
wish i could and i wish that i could
not have to deal with this [ __ ] and and
i every second day struggle with like
what if i just went back and i just
started working
my ass off and i did that but then it's
just gonna go straight back to where it
was
it has improved dramatically in all me
yes i have not fainted at all this year
that said
the last five days have been bad
um a lot of sleep very dizzy
but haven't fainted yet but i wouldn't
be surprised if it happened again
it's uh it's definitely a thing jog said
i have
daily shortness of breath and i just
want to punch my punch myself when it
triggers it's definitely this weird
thing where if you have an illness you
wish that it would just [ __ ] off and it
gives you this self-loathing
of like like i'm angry at myself for
something that i can't change
like i get mad you know it's just a
weird thing to
deal with did i see a doctor of course
i've had so many people on youtube like
q and a's be like you should see a
doctor about the fainting that's
dangerous are you
joking i had maybe like 50 doctors
appointments last year like
in and out of specialist office i spent
thousands of dollars majority of my
income last year went to specialist
doctors i went to doctors
so much it's definitely not a thing i
haven't done
yeah sorry for being very real here it's
just yeah it's a thing
i uh you know not not the hype uh
30k followers thing that i wanted to
jump on but here we are
i don't like you know dancing around it
i feel like and it's also helpful for
other people who maybe deal with these
issues to just
talk about it so yeah
are you able to do freelance work for
other companies while under contract to
sort of make up for the pay cut
yeah look freelance will never make up
for the pay cut but yeah i can
um i can do whatever i want now you know
i probably wouldn't have been allowed to
do play watch listen if i was still at
roosevelt so there are
definitely benefits to that
does my sickness happen because it's
stressful to work at funhouse or does it
happen in general it is
uh not related to working at funhouse
funhouse is not
well maybe it is but um no it's not like
because of funhouse it's
it's actually they suspect for me it's a
hormonal issue so i had a couple of
surgeries last year related to my
ovaries
but um yeah work stress definitely pays
into that and the most stressful part of
being at funhouse was the pressure of
people really wanting me to work harder
than i could and
maybe a little bit of resentmental anger
like my inability to do some things was
very difficult for me to deal with
uh why are subs disabled i don't like
exclusivity
thank you for answering that for me
scoot am i giving i appreciate that
it is [ __ ] hot isn't it what's up
jeff is benson is handsome irl as he is
on camera
oh my god benson
he's so perfect he's just the most
perfect creature
you don't understand sometimes he farts
and wakes himself up
and he's just really soft and fluffy
i call him chomsky honk i don't know why
i call him chomsky honk
but if i see benson i'm like hi benny
hey little chanka little chomsky honk
um
yeah he's a little chunky boy and i love
him a lot
is there any way you can support me look
there's a donate button on my twitch
that you can which i set up because
people kept asking um
you can donate on youtube but i try not
to like focus on that
because i am a person who does not do
this full-time and i do have income and
like while sure i'm not like
making very much money at all right now
like really
not much money i may have to move
apartments um
because i can support myself i don't
feel really right pushing for that
you know like i'm not going to stop
people but i also don't
try to make it a theme of my content
creation because it's
you know i can live i'm okay i'm doing
all right
um i had a patreon when i was at ign
which was literally because i couldn't
afford rent so i did set up patreon for
that period of time because i
absolutely needed to i could not live in
san francisco without having a patreon
uh but generally when i'm okay
i just don't really i don't know i don't
want to
um so i try not to but no now i do not
have a patreon
i don't need it i'm alright not
profiting traumatic dramatically i'm not
rich not making a ton of money
but uh i don't know point is i just
don't
don't want to focus on on making a lot
of money basically
how many mexicos did i stockpile you
know i've had trouble getting them
you're asked if i'm a wheat picks kid
yes dude i used to love wheat picks
i appreciate that qualification thank
you like obviously people donating is
still awesome for me and very helpful
but i don't try to push for it because
i feel like i'm already in a tremendous
position of of privilege
so i just try not to have i haven't
considered
acting um look i
love video games all i care about is
video games but i'm not against acting
i've done a little bit for
um some short films i have actor in all
my bios now which is just so that
publishers know that they can use me as
a voice actor for video games because i
love doing that but i wouldn't really
call myself an actor that's just so that
if someone reads that they know
that's a thing that i can do but um
not against acting but it's not
something i have interest in pursuing i
i just want to work in video games
forever or writing those are my two
hobbies
thank you axel i appreciate that did i
live in australia for a period of time
yes 21 years what about modeling uh [ __ ]
no
not a model hate modeling
i hate having my picture taken have i
considered uploading myself into a video
game
my face will be in a video game yes that
is a thing can't tell you what it is
yeah i'll act in video games i just
don't want to be like an and a
traditional
actor if that makes sense uh for
everyone asking about the xbox series
xtreme there is a video on my youtube
channel that went up at 9am this morning
if you wanna
check that out
what is it about you that got rejected
on a philippines
call center agency is this a this might
be like a very old story i lost a job at
a call center because the whole thing
got taken over
or you would just pull that on and
nowhere and it's a weird coincidence um
i lost a job at a call center because
they outsourced everyone to the
philippines
great cool
um love that okay just got a
dm
wow that's [ __ ] up
never mind okay how long can i speak in
an american accent um
i find it actually very easy to do an
american accent and i think that all
australians are actually really good at
it
uh because our accent is actually like
halfway between
the uk and america it's not actually
like
on some people would think in their head
to go like if there's a tally that the
uk would be in between the two
but australia being such a new country
and
uh during two separate wars having so
many americans move
into the country meant that we had you
know
very small population significant amount
of americans uh in the country for a
really long time
um it means that we had that influence
from the get-go anyway
that influenced the australian accent
going forward so
australians generally are very good at
doing american accents it's really easy
to do
i don't struggle with it at all i sound
more canadian
really how um
yeah so so american not difficult at all
um but i can also do a really good
british act british accent because
probably again
we're halfway between the two so i find
it really easy to do but with a british
accent it's also that my family is
british so my grandad
is actually from england so it's really
easy um
none of that is tough it's not hard uh
no the dm was not from a random person
it was from someone warning me about
something that they had seen
um hard w's are throwing you off hard
w's are
weird one thing that i always make fun
of the american accent for is the way
they say hawk
hawk h-a-a-k hawk
you know i can't do a scottish accent i
can do an irish accent pretty well i
think i'm not sure because i've not
spent that much time around many irish
people but scottish
i i cannot do really at all i find uh
doing the scottish accent really hard i
don't i just don't
quite understand how it works well i can
do different uh british accents too i
just my brain
goes to the one that sounds the most
like daisy ridley
so but i can do a bunch of accents
yes top of the morning to you
the welsh accent is my favorite accent
ever
sorry if i made you self-conscious about
the way you say hulk i think it's really
stupid americans say h-a-a-k
yo e-r sounds you out as australian
rubbish
i'd say hater i always put er on the end
of everything like
it's not i don't sound australian when i
do an american accent i don't think
anyone would know
of course you do kenneth just said it's
so weird also hi kenny
uh when i go downstate some people say i
have an accent law i don't think
alaskans have an accent everyone
has an accent americans are the only
people globally you go
and i think i really have an accent you
do everyone does
everyone in the entire world does
it's only ever americans that are like i
just don't have one of course you
[ __ ] do
the whole world has an accent god damn
no we say hawk h-a-w-k we say hawk
oh my god valley girl that's like super
easy that's like the easiest one for me
to do
the problem with me doing a valley girl
is that i also
have to change my entire personality i
can't do it without like acting like i'm
smiling the whole time and my eyes do
this weird [ __ ]
it's like i'm not even me when i do
valley girl i just like become a valley
girl and i don't know why
the new zealand accent is really easy
yeah
gosh you have one everyone has a [ __ ]
accent come on
uh good response to that that valley all
that thank you it's some of my finest
walk
i can't help it yeah i can do new
zealand new zealand's really easy to
i can't do south african
um i'm only just learning about the
scouse accent that's one that i could
practice
um i can't do
scottish it my brain always just goes
irish
i don't know why i know they sound
different but i can't do it so
thank you lighthammer you do [ __ ]
have an accent though you goddamn liar
everyone has an accent
it's only americans that are like i'm
the default
no you're not [ __ ] off everyone
has an accent um all right i'm gonna
actually start playing this game but
first just let me post
on the gram it's amazing
so amazing you know i'm planning to uh
to do a guitar cover of a song of that
song literally soon
um oh yeah i can do southern
i don't know that my southerner is very
good but i can do it
i don't know where i would be from i
don't know
you know i've not spent time anywhere
but in texas
but it's doable
i can do it
will have i made you a mod
i think i have right well scarlet
everybody
we did some uh some work together for a
game called teppin at a pax he's a good
dude
that's texas i'd guess so oh so new york
i actually have trouble with two because
i always go boston accidentally
just say y'all come here doggies with
this uh y'all come here doggies
is there a reason i'm saying that i
don't know what that would be a
reference to
i also go really floaty when i do
southern and i think it's because
i sound like dolores from uh what's the
name of that [ __ ] show
yeah like the second that i swap back
into australia and i go [ __ ] what's
the name of the phone show
mate it does sound pretty rdr2 you're
right
not wrong you're all right girl there's
a good girl
westworld thank you thank you yeah
boston i can do but that's
i i don't know if this is new york or
boston i'm not sure
which one it is maybe i just sound like
an italian
in new york i don't i don't know but
this one is funny because
sometimes when i do this accent it's
it's easier to do because the odds are
the same as the way i do in awe if i say
i'm in a car
sometimes people think that i'm from new
york or boston anyway because
australians kind of say odds the same
way
that we say odds also i feel like when i
do this i sound like a dude
it's jersey it's jersey
i just sound like kind of like a man i
can't really i can't do it like a
like i can't do russian also if you're
saying that they sound like a russian
that's well no what is this yet
yes this is maybe russian is it i'm not
i'm not sure european eastern european
it's just
can't do south african man i can't do it
it doesn't work
why is there an r sound at the end of so
fun fact
australians actually put rs at the end
of most words that end in a vowel
so i used to get made fun of this made
fun of for this a lot when i worked at
ign because you'd start a video of being
like
hey everyone i'm alana and welcome to
ign um mitch dyer particularly
who uh worked with me and ign at the
time is now a writer at
um uh ea montreal motive motif he's a
motive in montreal
uh would make fun of me for saying i'm
alana rand
you'd be like why do you put an r there
and it's actually just a very common
australian and british thing to do
is you put an r at the end of any word
that has a vowel a line or end
don't know why we do it we just do
it's just loops things together
on our end say gasoline in australian
gasoline but we don't say that we'd say
petrol
forget the game please just talk about
accents usually i would have started the
gameplay earlier than this that is my
bad
let me just tweet the thing i mean post
the thing playing
the outer world
come through i never know which one to
link people to
like i never know if i should do youtube
or twitch or what
or mixer like i feel like i just keep
changing it i'm just going to go
twitch this time because um
i i did want to celebrate
oh that was a good one the sub milestone
excuse me
twitch.tv carolinazod
and then we'll add a little little swipe
up gif in here a little swipe up
cool cool cool
the valley collection always made you
throw up why thank you
okay i shared it hopefully they will
come
[ __ ] it's amazing
so amazing everybody's fight up this
evening i really just skipped a lyric
so that's fine
let's play the [ __ ] video game um for
anyone who's not aware
[Music]
i am at the second planet i just left
the first planet got pavardi with me i
did not take
the um religious dude this time
because i think he kind of sucks
oh that's not true john jitsu you guys
are triggering me
when people sing they lose their accents
a lot incorrect
sentence doesn't make any sense when
people sing
they often put on an american accent
intentionally you do not ever lose your
accent because there is no such thing as
no accent everyone everywhere has an
accent
american is not the default i've had
people be like it's so weird you just
default to sounding normal when you sing
no i'm intentionally putting on an
american accent when singing
because i am mimicking the sound of the
person i'm singing as
i'm sorry get very triggered
if i were to sing in an australian
accent that song would be it's amazing
so amazing everybody's fired up this
evening
i still sound australian but plenty of
australians
sing an australian accent in australian
bands check out the greats big fan hey
girl hey
sometimes i wonder about mister who i
need to make my webcam what was he like
a little bit lower oops
i want to show you text there we go
now y'all could see it yeah american is
considered normal and it drives me nuts
you maybe wouldn't know that until you
uh live here but they're always like oh
you lose your accent nope putting on
another accent
your accent isn't the [ __ ] default
other people exist also america isn't
even
like the global majority whatever it's
fine
all right sometimes i wonder about mr
hawthorne what's he like
why'd he make the computer a talkie uh
this is the man who i stole the ship
from
why do i have to tell her to move along
i like what she asked i want to talk to
her about that
i guess not okay let's go
ground break a docking base we are only
taking her because we only have her
hot x
cultural volume is a really good way to
say that um grevin cultural volume not
population we have hollywood yes that's
why the american accent is so well
well known but it ain't default
you don't lose your accent when you sing
you just put on an accent
i have let met ashley butch we're in a
game together she's an off the body i
[ __ ]
love ashley butch huge fan
it's true american does also have a
really wide variety of accents
so yeah which one would you pick when
you say american accent
who knows
um okay hey captain
i'm in space i never thought i'd be able
to say that
that's so cute you're so welcome
something you need no i was just trying
to
i always want to talk to her and it
never lets me oh good crouch let's go
over here uh what is my quest right now
yes we do want to do that companion i
did really want to do that let's do that
first let's take you to
jun lay tennyson this pitch on matt this
pitch on map
cool cool i do want to talk to everyone
though don't i well i've already done it
it's fine it's fine it's fine who are
you though hey what's up
careful where you smoke group builds us
for air filtration
i'm not smoking what the [ __ ] i'm gonna
lip you with me [ __ ]
uh i can't get through here okay hello
identification please yes hello
i am definitely hawthorne
captain hawthorne you said let me
apologize in advance
i'm about to ruin your day oh [ __ ]
according to your ship's record you've
been flagged by the board
your ship will be impounded and tied
such a time as they see fit to lift it
goodbye aaron or maybe hello i don't
know which one is this game on steam
no hold on i think it might be epic game
store actually
uh now hold on this is the end of the
okay how do i get this i want to take it
up with udom
bedford our board representative
groundbreaker
cool his office is located along the
starboard wall of the promenade
shines like a byzantium love it cool
can't wait
let's do it access to that information
is above my pay grade
and i've turned down three promotions so
it stays that way
i shouldn't be mentioning it but what
the hell
this here in pounding your ship it
doesn't happen much you think they know
that he's dead we don't take kindly to
their interfering in our operations
that's why i have to take a guess as to
why you must have riled up someone
important
did i play the game before yeah i did
already stream this game forever ago
also yes
correct um if i had to take a guess as
to why you must have riled up someone
important
okay you take the starch out of them
well you won't hear any complaints
didn't need to tell me that that way
would you mind doing me a favor it
depends what it is
sure won the door set over in sickbay
telepathy
what difficulty am i playing as i don't
probably normal i don't remember
sam cleaning units retrofitted for
surgery i generally don't love the
combat in this game though
i'm in it for the talking
uh got it much appreciated is there
anything
i have been doing every quest so um
sure yeah on your left when you enter
the promenade
cool make sure you bring an empty belly
is that a threat
can i find a job around here maybe most
of the shipping traffic in the system
passes through the ground breaker
yeah joe kelly it is we even get a big
interstellar crater
two biggest operations are the board
that is halcyon holdings and sometimes
but they're independent i don't know i
think you may have said that once before
and i don't know what you're talking
about take you off station though
sure you're on sugarpine 7 what was it
like being interrogated by stephen i
couldn't he kept a straight face i mean
he and i were friends way before that
video obviously
um i miss them being in the office i
really liked hanging out with those
dudes
um no it wasn't difficult it's fine
it's insane though i already did the
first planet yes this is
on the second planet did everything on
the first planet i'm trying to do pretty
much everything in this quest
sorry this playthrough um should we show
you our station though
i can't leave yet something like that
ships and abandoned outposts
and encourage folks to abandon their
stats
sublight gives me the creeps i've known
folks who went to work for them and just
vanished corporation bad they're on the
promenade run by a woman named
capitalism i'm only telling you you hear
me far more than the average eagle
you've never heard me fart
it's a thing i don't do very often i'm
sure all women want to say that but
i burp a lot not a lot of thoughts no
okay
all right cool ah i didn't mean to do
that
okay you need anything else yeah good
day
can i go through now yes yes yes yes yes
yes i just want to help pavardi out you
know i just want to set her up
that's it i picked up this weird signal
i'm definitely not an ego but also i'm
not offended call me what you want who
cares
been called everything under the sun you
know at this point
is this [ __ ] people say it's ridiculous
it uh
never ends oh i'd love to take this but
that would be theft oh there's nothing
in it
this is this the sick bay i was going to
say is this this
sick woman in here maybe
is this the sickbay
no it is close though
why is there red on the map i didn't
expect that
whoa so pretty neon
neil said wanted to ask you what plans
to go half-life alex and the
blah blah i love you taking a how can
past your video um
look i've been trying to figure out how
to do half-life alex being that
i have a very small space and a green
screen um i can't
figure out how to capture that gameplay
to talk about that game which is what i
would want to do
um uh looks like he's from the ear
so in theory yeah i'd like to but i'd
have to figure out the technical side
please don't make a scene
i am not making a scene
drama no if she's literally not she
didn't say anything i can help you with
yes hello
well that's not what i wanted i just
wanted to go in here
am i allowed that [ __ ] wasn't allowed
why am i allowed hello
can't say i've seen you before i take it
you're afraid i might be
am i going to stream this whole play
through yourself you'll have to wait
probably not we're having a spot of
trouble with our delivery service well i
know that i can
do a standing space and still enjoy the
game my point is um holland
that it's issues with recording it that
i'm having playing the game by myself
perfectly fun
recording it more complicated
wait does youtube say that i'm playing a
playtale i thought i updated it
troy baker never heard of him
if you're here to better yourself you'll
have to wait you have a spot of trouble
uh yes
uh that's it he must be referring to
irion
i'm sure the fool's gotten himself into
another school it happens
i'm beginning to wonder oh good luck
with your assignment bin what's it about
um
who's our delivery man is he dead a
brave idiot with a penchant for getting
himself delayed
sometimes by dates usually oh my god
anthony
i don't know what that's in relation to
but he just said bread cheese is good
it's cheese you throw in a frying pan
and melt it all up
that sounds incredible that's
the best sounding thing i've ever heard
oh my god no more streaming animal
crossing i'll totally stream our animal
crossing just not today
i did want to play this so i'm glad that
it was chosen
uh lulu he said any small space vr tips
my partner and i live in a tiny
apartment and haven't set up our vr yet
but hope to figure something out soon
get a quest play it in a bathroom
it still says oh i need to update that
let me update youtube
maybe it didn't save um but if you
already have something else there aren't
really any tips
there is no simple solution
videos live
edit this i'm not playing a plaguetail
more options
the outer welts done
safe
cool um okay
what do you need mechanicals surgery
mostly medical personnel are difficult
to come i have training in medical
for the record the board won't let their
doctors and nurses station here
and they own all the medical schools if
we can't
we can't hire anything too real everyone
on staff here on
does anyone make grilled cheese on a
grill my stepdad does
but we've only two heads between us and
we don't know everything ah the chat's
interconnected they are for me
um restream has a chat thing that puts
everything together i don't know if
there's any other way for you guys
i mean i could probably put all the
chats on the screen
but that would not look great but i
could show you what it looks like
if i just do that real quick what would
it be window capture probably
there we go restream chat okay
show you how it looks
or not did not show up
it looks like it's there
but if i did it if i move it acro no
won't work all right i'd have to figure
it out
off stream probably but um yeah they're
all together for me so
everyone on stuff here in ground break
was trained by mirror idris what good
don't get me wrong
okay all right grateful the time we need
his delivery
last he told me he was taking a shortcut
oh i'd have to fly off point after that
you look out though not now woman
whoa all right pavardi nothing off of my
[ __ ]
restriction access oh why the what it's
just a
quarantine this shit's too real why is
she so up in my space
do i like l.a or new york city better i
like new york better as like a place to
visit
uh but that question is very confusing
ultimately
we can't do that because we're not going
to silla
weapons from the void we need to go to
phineas
science weapon what i don't know he's
got something on the ground breaker what
is it
um acquire the science weapon on ground
breaker the logs on hawthorne's terminal
mentioned rumors from the groundbreaker
of a scientist who bragged about a
powerful weapon he was researching
perhaps more details can be found
on the station another of hawthorne's
logged mentioned looking in gladys shop
for old records
okay
it seems like it's going to be illegal
but i'll go for it
let's give it a shot have i done
anything with d and d
you know what i've never played dandy
i'm positive i would love it
but um no i've never had a group of
friends to play it i'd love to
a stranger thank you andrew i'm really
enjoying making the podcast thank you
for listening i appreciate that you're
here for
my hair looks great today thanks i feel
like it looks terrible
sugar cookies are i appreciate it made
without a single natural ingredient
or an oven just like store bought
i'm here for phineas those have been the
height of illegality since stellar bay
turned their noses up at the board
you and i could be thrown this game's so
impressive for discussing such a
transaction okay
lucky for us groundbreaker's a free port
we're outside of the board's control
for the time being now i only have the
one
am i from south brisbane and they're
hard to come by these days no i'm from
camps
if you find yourself lacking in the bits
i might have an opportunity you'd be
interested in
uh yeah i i i for that people asking
about hair
yeah it's uh i did what i said i would
in that video which is just
dust shampoo toner that's it
now i only have the one napkin you know
how to come by it won't be cheap
i do need it oh i don't have a thousand
bits
okay
nice any chance of disc genius that old
kook
he was quite the dancer back in his
private he was real light on his feet
he didn't mention it light in the wallet
too
he still owes me a small fortune loss
maybe i should charge you i didn't go
how i wanted
uh real like the wallet to use me so
okay let's just go with
opportunity well i find i'm in need of a
ship captain with a little
moral flexibility might be this could
help out the groundbreaker
as well as earn some bits well what do
you mean by that if you've got qualms
hear the details do you know edna over
in engineering
did i ever review their dfinity games
i'm interested in the new bald escape 3.
uh i did a preview of baldur's gate 3 on
inside gaming go check that out
i saw it it's good recording of a
distress signal she'd scraped from the
groundbreaker's comarray
curious thing is it came from an outpost
called roseway
and angie cleo abandoned that place
years ago okay
why would throw his way back can't say i
know for sure
maybe it never really was [ __ ] what
that mean com centers don't operate
themselves captain
someone had to have sent that distress
call manually it's true
those corpse are cleverer than all get
out
might have been a ruse to keep the rest
of the board from sniffing around
okay
yeah i'll do it you've got an ear for
intrigue and a nose for bits
i like that i like this woman here's a
copy of the sos recording complete with
the coordinates this is cool
cool question find a secret worth
selling i'm done might be i could find a
buyer
corporate bigwigs will pay top bit for
inside information on the thoughts on uh
cyberpunk's general customization
fighting each other cool why not the
last time they got to meddle in our
affairs
i don't know why people keep talking
about pear character have i missed some
kind of meme
i don't know what you're talking about
uh
is anyone from funhouse still involved
with inside gaming or is the ig crew
holding it down the ig crew is holding
it down
omar is involved but that's about it
good night kyle have a good one thanks
for joining
uh what did anthony say
divinity original sin one and two are
fantastic games yeah but i actually had
an issue with the first one too so
uh the more we got the cops fighting
each other yes correct got it don't
forget to come find old gladys when
you're done
well i liked you up until you said that
you weird [ __ ]
all right cool
um
yeah i'm not gonna be able to do that am
i oh i'm not gonna do any of this
let's do this no i'm not on cello i
can't get to cilla
just stressing all i can't do until i
get back to my ship weapons from the
void
yeah we can still do the rest of
it's this it's so amazing
and everybody's back i keep skipping a
line when i'm singing that song
i've already spoken to you woman trying
to get through here do i need to go up
maybe
should i go this way see what happens
this seems right
cool cool cool cool did i just go in a
circle
hmm
oh is it sending me back to the ship
well
i guess let's see what happens anyway if
i'm allowed to get on
and do the things or if it's just stuck
clamped
yeah hello hey there you mind stepping
back
this charming little ship's been
impounded and i'm afraid i can't let you
near it till it's not
[ __ ] okay i'd surely love to
but that's just not my baileywick you'll
want to have words with our
representatives here from the board
chuck don't touch me
i wouldn't dream of it not unless i got
she's a good ship ma'am
mostly doesn't act up at all it's true
happy to hear it
thank you i hate felt so much as the
tepid breeze it
well it doesn't smell as bad here as
edgewater's graveyard in high summer
so cool oh i'm starting to feel like a
sisty roast in all this i hate her
no one should be that pleasant it's
unsettling
you're struggling to enjoy bioshock fun
fact i don't like playing bioshock but i
love bioshock
i have a few games like that where i
don't like playing them i don't have fun
doing it
but i like the game itself because of
the experience i suppose bioshock is one
of those for me
get someone to play it for you i keep
[ __ ] going the wrong way so i don't
have any reason to go back to gladys
what am i doing right now
um we're gonna need to do this
i want to talk to bedford
where he at though i think the 30 meter
one is gladys right yeah no we ain't
going there we're going to bedford bro
take me to the big leagues
this is super cool pancakes
just a good food uh
okay is are we just being spammed is
that what's happening here
it's a raid okay well
is there something i need to do about
that or are we just fine
welcome i guess hi when might we expect
you out here again
it's uh they're a very persistent raid
but not a lot of them
thank you tash
i appreciate it
everybody's fired up this evening
yeah i don't know if youtube does raids
or if it was just that a bunch of people
like they
they made them go there
i don't know
cool though yeah the viewers haven't
gone up like really at all
that's the weird part so that's why i
was like
persistent but not many of them it's
like
maybe up by 10 or maybe it's just
catching up i don't know
but thanks
um
okay let us keep going
we need to go talk to udon bedford
he's going to be y'all going to let me
in
apparently yes every i love that all of
this game is just people sitting in
rooms at desks waiting for you just like
i'm ready all right hi
ah yes wheeler messaged me you were
coming you must be the captain of the
unreliable
i am a vessel that used to be helmed by
one alex hawthorne [ __ ]
and you are not he they're on to me
it's true happened i am not he scruffy
freelancer
uh has something happened to my favorite
scruffy freelancer
alex is dead correct and
no i didn't kill him i didn't kill him
my dear he kind of killed himself
accidentally
but he did and whose miserable fever
dream am i
trapped wow
i'm sorry i feel lost oh alex
there was so many it's all my fault i
didn't kill him it's not my fault
uh what was your relationship with him
he was my dearest friend oh [ __ ]
well that's a huge bummer dude that
sucks for you you must know
his literal only friend me hugging him
him wincing i keep a copy beside my bed
did he uh i haven't looked
yes ah that's just like him
probably shouldn't have lied about that
but i felt bad even though i didn't kill
him
how did he die he got crushed right
right
yeah oh awful business that
well it was his own fault no no
best not to ask after the gory details
did i finish ff7 remake shall i have fam
it's great um
awful business but why how again very
sorry
i expected this dude to be mad but he's
very sweet there is a good amount of
character variety in this game it's not
like everyone's predictable actually
this game's really [ __ ] well written
who am i getting from your ship
thank you you're terribly sorry for the
inconvenience however before you go
alex promised to tell me the location of
phineas wells
i'm sure you've seen his wanted posters
all over the comments i don't know that
i want to sell phineas out tell you
where wells might be
anything at all
yeah okay you haven't read the posters
is it terroristic even a madman
terrorist he's my only friend
just like it's really alex he's not
hawthorne
it was only your only friend
alex didn't mention phineas wells to be
fair alex
i think never said anything to me about
phineas wells
i don't want to sell him out terrible
news
oh what am i going to do now the
board will have my head because why
don't you just say too many damn
freckles
i have tons of freshwaters you just
usually can't see them because i really
like it
tons of them covered in them
i'm sorry it's terribly unprofessional
to me is there anything else i might
help you with
um what is this about the board having
your head
it's personal business i'm afraid uh
miserably
am i going for a good guy or a bad dude
factory actually play rpgs unless it's a
predetermined character
kind of the way i would play it um which
is mostly good
occasionally a little bit gray like i
think very very very hard about the
choices that i make in this game
um but yeah i don't i don't try to do
good or bad i just do what i think i
would do in that situation which is i
don't know
it surprises me that more people don't
play games like that
like i would think most people would
play rpgs that way
it's personal because i'm afraid and
miserably terribly personal is there
anything i can do to help i like him the
whereabouts of phineas wells would go a
long way
no it's well i don't want to give him up
i'm sorry
i suppose
no i'm not doing fine really it's
perfectly fine
i understand now if you have nothing
else
please see yourself out i'd like to
drown myself in work
that dude is depressed you have
depression if ever i've seen it
okay good day goodbye oh oh [ __ ]
oh we level up here [ __ ]
okay nope uh what do we got ten
i like ranged i like dialogue and i like
tech i'm gonna do more now i'm actually
already smashing dialogue by so much
right now
but i did want to get to that 50.
see now i can do lie even more so that's
cool right let's do two of those
what do i need for after 50 for that too
that's that's nuts
couple there couple on ranged
try not to use it too much then just
more on dialogue i reckon dialogue
it is oh look at me [ __ ] go
count up every single one of those
smooth
[ __ ] talker i love it i love it
you think that bedford had a crush on
hawthorne
it didn't read that way to me i guess he
could have it just seemed like there
were real good buds like really
passionate
best friends you know
um okay cool ship's good
uh i still need to get the nav key
so let's do the job for gladys the
distress signal on tara too
let's [ __ ] do it this place is dope
though
it seems weird that there isn't more to
do here
he's sort of the reason i'm alive so
not telling you [ __ ] it'd be real messed
up if i if i screwed him over hello
gregory oh it says greasy
hello potential customer thank you
welcome to auntie's kitchen
a home style consumable protein
dispensary for this unit dispense
proteins for your ingestion
i love this adjusting units audio
receiver input levels
for more suits engagement with customers
are you going to yell at me
i thought why would you say that i don't
dispensing sequence
i mean i didn't actually want to argue
with him i'm fine i don't need anything
drop a squat uh okay
this place is cool what is this
the armory i guess i could buy some new
[ __ ] i'm i'm level seven
so i don't need any consumables but i
could use some of this motion
maybe it's a bit second hand but that's
only testament that's done yeah
uh y2jazz i'm talking my way through
most of the games i'm
avoiding repel borders uh most combat
because i don't think it's
very enjoyable in this game i don't like
it that much
um i love the the dialogue though so
i am doing that most of the time
it's a good game fam it's a good game
okay
let's see what you've got it's it's it's
proper armor that i want to take a look
at
four thirteen bruv i'm [ __ ] ages away
from oh no no it's level seven it's it's
it's level seven i could do that i could
do that
i'll go [ __ ] with that no i can't afford
it
it looks so cool though
i have zero bits right now [ __ ] when
did that happen
sheesh all right
cool coco say consumables again
consumables consumables how do you say
tissue no i know you want
you want being mean i'm sorry i default
to aggression even when i'm happy
all right let's [ __ ] go figure out
this [ __ ] about this signal
sounds dope to me dog
it's amazing so amazing
yeah what's up felix he's kind of hot i
don't know each other yet
i just like a boy with messy hair that's
really
discussion the rest of it honestly
doesn't even matter you just gotta have
messy hair and then i'm like
hello thinking you might be looking for
some crew i want your feet
you know just to take a closer look i
don't know why i hand it to you
you are unsure if this game is good on
this game is definitely good missing
is a very good game dude
i'm literally broke in real life and in
game my dude
you're right i do love bad head
which to be fair okay i also always have
messy hair so it's not like i'm putting
unrealistic expectations on men
i also have messy hair all the time so
me liking that
it's even
describe this game using only one
australian phrase
we don't really have any australian
phrases
bloody butte i suppose
okay uh let's find like a chip only
thing missing it's me i don't
really yes i
absolutely am i don't know you just give
me a shot that's all but who are you
i could be the best damn crew you ever
hired but literally who are you who the
[ __ ] are you
yes you're serious you're giving me a
shot no all right
uh hang on hang on if i didn't say that
i put together a little speech just
i stream on twitch yeah actually i'm on
twitch right now hey there i just want
them to have hair
not messy dogs it's gonna be messy i
believe you should like the disheveled
blood to join the crew of your ship and
or outlaw gang
okay go on
firstly i am highly personable and i get
along well with anyone who is not of the
jackass persuasion i believe you
i'm sorry he's funny are you flooding
with another man in front of me
i can be counted on in the event [ __ ] a
fire fight
standoff and or rape my motto
is if you need a steady gun hand i'm
your man
motto is a work in progress i'm
genuinely undecided
continue additionally i have several
years of experience as a box hauler
this skill may come in handy if you need
a body dragged away or a door held open
while escaping enemy fire
okay that does sound handy thank you for
considering me for your ship crew and or
outlaw gang
i look forward to our adventures
together
i thought that was real good felix she
likes him
confidence what do you think um
i think i'm gonna allow it
interview sure an interview that sounds
fair
i mean first time i love this ask me
anything you like
he's making a move on me well i am a
male character he could be gay i don't
know but
i am playing as a man i also have a
moderately big dick
i am uh reasonably girthy also
okay
uh it's delicious
apple pie and a triple kale crust maybe
with a little cream on top
classic it wasn't a great answer
uh biggest flaw oh i love that one i
always say mornings
i told them my problem it's not with
authority it's with jackasses
so yeah i guess my biggest flaw is that
i don't suffer idiots
i hope that's not a deal breaker
uh why are you out of work i have this
foreman right
yeah guy never liked me i'm always
trying to get a rise out of me why
but i keep my chin up right be the
bigger man i tell myself
he's a spacer's chosen man though so
when the chosen beat my rangers the
other night
my foreman comes swaggering up with his
head full of boasting
okay this isn't it's i don't think that
[ __ ] talking your ex employee
employer is ever a great look
that's when i broadsided him with a toss
ball doesn't love that
that was your worst answer yet it was a
long time coming guy thinks he can push
me around
this is a bit of a red flag man i was on
board until you you said all of this
guess i just tendered my resignation
[ __ ] what do i do you guys i liked him i
was on board with just having another
hand to help her out on the ship
seems like a thing that would make sense
until he [ __ ] talked and murdered his
ex-employer because he was arrogant
what do i do give me spoilers all right
you would you would not base this on
what you know is going to happen
based on this interview solely what are
we doing
not based on [ __ ] that happens in the
game only based on this
getting a lot of airlocks i don't i
don't know it's it's got to be just a
you're hired
or a no
higher em bullet in the face
not good enough
i think we're mostly getting get him
take him so i'm gonna do it but i'm
always gonna keep an eye on him because
what you did to your ex-employer was
[ __ ] up and the way that you [ __ ] took
them after you left
that's real rude man am i doing it for
now
you don't know how long i've been
waiting to hear that thanks how long
have you been out of work you're not
going to regret this
i might we'll see you now felix all
right
he does look much hotter from a distance
though like from here oh [ __ ] who is he
oh damn but like when you're up here
it's fine you know
it's just like me all right
let's go
i do simp for messy hair yeah it's true
that's what's up he looks like zayn
malik i think zayn malik is shockingly
attractive
he does not look that much like st malik
good night alexis thanks for joining
what's my opinion on cricket
god just so boring just so boring
all right good
you're back not that i missed you i
assure you
i am not capable of such emotional
capacity hello
captain thank you
we got places to go fam
yes captain beginning playback now
there's there's visceral in debt
everywhere oh that's not good
for last sake if anyone's receiving this
please send help it's probably a bit
late in it
it's probably no no no
well i don't love the way that sounds
the roseway landing pad okay also
corporate protocol requires that all
distress signals include a list of key
personnel for retrieval
the embedded names are anton the
unemployed rose up is that what he's
implying an orson shaw
how is it late andy cortez it's 7 40 or
did you mean it was late in terms of
in terms of me going there in which case
yeah they're probably all dead that's my
bad
uh also critical requires yes we know
that okay
cool okay if the unemployed were the
ones that rose up then i personally
am in support of it i love that
socialist [ __ ]
more often um
okay let's [ __ ] go dude
wait i don't remember how to fly it's
been a long time since i played this how
do i
is it there we go uh is it terra 2
no
surely not oh no it is okay it is
literally a terror too
the roseway landing pad let us go all
right
let's go the stream quality is
pig is that good or bad i don't know
what that means teach me your slang
hmm is your character up for anything
where he can use a gun
i mean i imagine this mission will
involve gun
but i don't like the combat in the game
so
did we do it are we here bro we [ __ ]
did it
let's go oh it's this way let's go
sure fine i guess no you're staying on
the ship that's when it's just pervading
rocky desert flower just said is this
just me or is this a story
story a knockoff of fallout fun fact
this is made by obsidian entertainment
who made
fallout new vegas they are the og
fallout team
so if it seems like a knockoff of
fallout it is because in part
they made fallout
all right uh if you just like cricket
how do you feel about baseball baseball
is also boring
cricket is more boring than baseball
paperwork or ticketing or whatever
that's true i imagine this place is
abandoned based on that distress signal
this is pretty i could make this an
animal crossing
little ramps and lots of like trees and
flowers and stuff that's really cute
okay i don't have any cash we both know
that what do i
want to use that's my grenade launcher i
think
pistol's garbage i want that light
machine gun back i think this is
that's probably my grenade launcher i've
forgotten how they look
light pistol it's the that's a grenade
launcher yeah light machine gun
that's what we want fam this thing's
pretty legit
what was that what was that what was
that nothing
all right let's take a look around you
know see what things you have
for me to take those are empty i guess
i don't have any money can't be [ __ ]
with any of that [ __ ]
all right cool neat oh
can't even get through it
how do i feel about the potential return
of the premier league
i don't feel like i'm the person to
answer that question you know that's up
to
powers much higher and greater than me
um very expensive industry
with a lot of very expensive contracts
oh dead man
oh [ __ ] captain something
oh bro yeah i'm gonna take that damn
[ __ ] legit helmet what i don't know
if i can
upgrade my armor right now
it is all really low level but it's what
i have
this game is lacking need something just
feels empty do you think
i totally disagree but i think it
depends on what you want right like this
is this is an rpg
this game is very much like a tabletop
game made into a video game there are
lots of games that apply to but um
this game is very much about
specking your character deciding how to
approach things
dialogue the story the factions it's not
uh
run around and shoot stuff game so it's
not that kind of game
related joe poop said anything you
dislike about this game
um yeah the combat
um brookie 91 the inside xbox thing uh i
have a video up on my youtube channel if
you want to talk about that
evicted okay this place has been shut
down for a while i think
oh it's going to be locked okay
[ __ ] i ain't got that kind of money
damn are you okay there
sweet robert boy you're very cute
hey i'll take all that
well i mean there's nothing on the path
dude you can chill out
just take a look around
hmm
oh are you alive you are
oh there was three of you okay uh time
dilation
why'd you run away little [ __ ] punk ass
[ __ ]
that's the last of them okay
seems like there should probably be more
i will take your meats thank you
oh can i wear that armor
i can great it doesn't look as cool
that see that looks like some destiny
[ __ ] and i like it but this stuff's high
level
it's only six what is it
stealth skills yeah yeah i'll [ __ ] with
that
why was that noise so dramatic give me
all your things thank you
hmm old journal dad
i'm writing this on the odds that you
found your way back here i'm sorry i
wasn't here to see you
they're moving us out of town all of us
i don't know where we're going hoping
that wherever it is they've got a lab as
nice as roseway's
we're doing some good work real science
for once
i don't know why they're moving us and i
don't know when we'll see each other
again
and dad do me a favor and bone this
journal
he [ __ ] didn't i'm not allowed to
even mention the name
roseway as far as corporate's concern
this town
never existed i don't want to get in
trouble
whenever i do anything like reading i
immediately go very australian
um well he didn't burn it let's take a
nap sure yeah i just sleep for
six hours sure why not i love a nap
okay uh
any tips to someone who suffers with
mental health and is living alone in
lockdown
listen brookie91 you said i'm always
good for advice when it comes to mental
health
i'm not i always just want to say i'm
not a mental health professional
i wish i could help you um and it's so
subjective you know like
something that might work for me doesn't
work for you um i'm not alone in
lockdown so i'm not struggling with that
generally like what i would say is my
very uneducated opinion i don't want
anyone to suffer obviously would be
call people as much as you can play
games online see if there's a community
you could find on a game like destiny or
wow obviously still goes off but um
yeah i don't feel like i can help much
more than that
um working out does help a lot
but um that's again i don't ever want to
force that on anyone if it doesn't work
for them
it's i can't imagine being alone during
lockdown must be really tough
um yeah i can't i feel like i'd go nuts
or maybe i wouldn't i don't know i'm
alone a lot of the time anyway but
yeah i'm sorry i am
honestly try try finding a clan in a
game online
see if that helps that would that could
work
okay [ __ ] i know okay
taking all your [ __ ] oh what we got
there what we got there
is it better or is it worse yeah that is
an assault rifle that's
215 dps that's a bitch-ass assault rifle
oh can't get in there right just trying
to slowly wander around
okay [ __ ] off trying to see that's
locked
how big is this place
uh oh this is a pretty small area but
unless that's fog of wall i'm not sure
doesn't seem that big though
hello another door you ever get into
valorent
look i have played a bit of it and i
like it and i want to play more of it i
definitely never want to stream that
game though because
they did yeah they did um
because there are certain games that are
not fun to stream when you're learning
them
and that's a game that i still have a
lot of learning to do i feel like people
would be like you're not doing this
right and i'd be like shut up let me
learn
so i don't want to i don't want to
stream it but i do like it for sure um
i've had some games where i did great
and some games rated [ __ ] terrible
it uh varies of course
which game is my favorite combat the
arkham series dude
so good
what was that what was that noise it did
not like
whatever that was hmm
that is red flag whatever this noise was
all right i think that's it okay all
right
naga sheesh
just to be clear i said nago there's
definitely an a in there
it didn't it didn't disrupt something
something else it was
it was yes it was definitely an a
uh okay
it's amazing it's so amazing
yeah i'll take your meats and then we'll
go in the roseway
what a secret scared accent was that i
was for sure
quoting uh uh what we do in the shadows
you should watch it it's very good
i've already spoken about dnd a bunch
people keep asking though
um no i have not played d d i would love
to never have
never i've gotten close a bunch of times
and then like schedule's been a problem
or something
um but i'd really like to
all right we made it everybody's [ __ ]
dead
music's nice it's a little minecrafty
yeah take all your [ __ ] bits
i don't care looting in the apocalypse
[ __ ] yeah dude i don't give a [ __ ]
security blade i got a sword hello
i don't have enough of this [ __ ] okay
i'm just the [ __ ] tarmac guard
no one said nothing about it didn't
fight no raps i i just
walked up to you i didn't ask about any
of this
so
did you send a distress call distress
call from here
[ __ ] they told me that weren't allowed
someone did got me
i just do what i'm told and i was told
not to do so
somebody did what happened alarms went
off
raps broke and i hightailed it in here
so was the raps who killed everyone it
wasn't
the unemployed
do i miss funhouse i mean i just made a
fun house video today what you mean fam
being in the office
yeah yeah i do
alarms enough raps broke loose and i
hightailed it in here to get a wall
between me and that beast
okay um wraps broke loose you haven't
caged up um
forget i said anything about that you
already told me
what can you tell me about them wish
they tasted like [ __ ] pig
that was good they really [ __ ] love
[ __ ] pig in this universe
thank you lionel do i miss ign i miss my
friends at ign all the time
yeah some of my best friends ever still
work in that building
uh that's helpful don't mention it
sarcastic book anything else you'd like
to know being sarcastic
you tell me who's in charge scientists
name a anton
crane someone said he's panicking inside
all right
let me go give him a talking to
what we doing outside what do you think
i'm the landon pad guard i was standing
out on the [ __ ] target got it
cool hell of a job until all this
guy's voice does not match his face at
all you think
all right bye oh before i forget
anticlio's makes the best
pharmaceuticals in helsion
better than nature not like that crap i
think this is my first anti-clio's quest
in this one actually
factions be factioning
i'm just taking a look around stealing
all your [ __ ]
hello cutie cute little friend
cool i mean who's gonna see though right
who's gonna see who's gonna see
boom ain't nobody that's who
but i didn't take the weapon parts i
only took the bits okay i only took your
gosh dang money not your supplies
because i
am poor i feel like even you'd
understand you'd be like that [ __ ] came
in here with no bits
she took 15 or whatever it was not the
end of the world
hello i heard you were panicking if
you've come to end my life
let's be on with it oh not actually one
of them are you
no i'm not
yes yes anton craig all right what about
the unemployed tell me about them give
me a stance
that will decide whether you die or not
i
may have panicked everything um ricky
who is yelling i want silver hair just
watch my youtube video
i talk about it there's you're on
youtube you sent that from youtube chat
check my my silver hair dying video
that's you'll find out all you need to
know fam
that's it if you have good persuasion
bro i have the best persuasion i need
better persuasion to get
to get a freebie when stealing even
better than i already have
now it's so well i guess i'm actually
very early in the game so what do i
[ __ ] know
i must apologize if my call divided you
i may have panicked everything's under
control now though two people under
control
what are you hiding i'm not at liberty
to discuss the nature of the work i'm
doing then why did you send a distress
call you big [ __ ] dummies
to the colony is immeasurable probably
shouldn't have broadcast a signal
my research may not quite fall within
legal parameters
so i'm under orders to maintain wireless
silence
however having your head used as target
practice can add
she's thinking i caught the call
immediately once i've gathered my wits
the home office can't know what's
happening here okay
intimidate captain's got your best
interests at heart mister
honest i suppose it can't hurt
did i really intimidate that i don't
feel like i did that wasn't a very
intimidating line
we were tasked with formulating a new
and improved dental gel
okay that's illegal
one cannot exaggerate the benefits of
good dental hygiene
may i continue yes sorry go ahead
while doing research on enzymes specific
to the raptodon's digestive system we
developed an additive which we
subsequently discovered to be the most
effective appetite suppressant
okay he made weight loss pills
accidentally is that what you're saying
sure not just any diet it's actually a
pretty good idea
an appetite suppressant that's also
toothpaste would
probably sell pretty well in the real
world
i think
yeah loose streams you can kill pretty
oh it wasn't sorry it was it was
collate you can kill pretty much
everyone but i try to kill as few people
as possible
do it when i have to how often do i need
to dye my hair to diet silver
uh you just watched the video man same
as anyone else who has
colored hair same as literally everyone
else
um okay
i don't want to be so rude to him let's
just what do you need for me hours ago
a group of vicious malcontents fell upon
us
shut up our labs and loosed our research
subjects
the raptor if those cretins get their
hands on my research
well they'll need not kill me because
your employer is well
uh okay yes
but don't kill their mother the mother
wrapped it on we've need of her to
replenish our stocks
i think there's gas in the lab so okay
that can be used to put them out
and our searches i want to hear what the
what the need of my code and key card
the others have to say though
i don't know if i agree that you've been
if you just
follow the road you'll pass by the town
doing the right thing
by the grand architect will you be an
evil to these animals is that what
they're gonna tell me
okay who is he my protege
i sent him got it
i'll find him too many have been lost
too many okay cool
everything is so sassy um okay i want
why is that not opened up more
oh i didn't do that i should have done
that um
this is a sidequest i'm doing right now
it's giving me more okay that's what i
kind of thought
that's what i'm trying to do okay fine
ant on safe is number one
no it's not it's it's it's it's
the lab's gas is what i want am i in the
lab right now i think he's in the calm
center
and that doesn't seem to be anything
leading me to said lab
so out we go about dr crane's research
but we ought to find mr jameson
yeah is that what i selected it is right
oh is that yeah
i mean it's all pretty much the same
direction
let's go
because sometimes i get so confused
about what chats are talking about to
each other
oh anthony said not realizing he was
being completely sarcastic what did he
say
i probably knew oh yeah of course i knew
you said my money is on once at least
every five years of course i knew that
i didn't think you were being serious um
no a lot of the time and it
confuses people on twitter mostly
um i answer people to answer for
everyone so i'm not answering that
individual person
individual yep that one sounded weird to
me i'm basically like
uh where are we going dude am i getting
back on the ship
surely not no i'm going out here okay
that means i went the wrong way
uh yeah i answer a question so that
everyone else can hear the answer to
that question rather than just to that
one person
which is like if you even if you the
rest of your comment is
sarcastic if the start of it is how
often do you have to do it i answer that
question
for everyone's knowledge not just for
that one person which i know is a weird
way to communicate
but i feel like when you're streaming or
if you are always speaking to a lot of
people even by accident by virtue of
social media
oh hello here they come that's too many
things coming for me at once it's not
what i intended
[ __ ] marauders as well [ __ ]
okay i'm gonna run on ammo i think too
i don't i don't want this i didn't want
any of this there were too many of you
you should be dead by now
i don't want to use my ammo man let's
change
to melee weapon
bye also by
one more
[ __ ] marauders i just saw one dude
and then the whole world was on me
yeah [ __ ] you
right in the head
yeah how many more were there two maybe
oh he's almost dead anyway
is that it is that it is that it i
didn't want any of this
i think that is it though oh well that's
pervading it's fine
boom take all the things
all right i don't need any of you
they're probably going to be more of
them though it's fine it goes it's not
like they're hard to kill
i just didn't want to i just didn't want
to
oh that's a mine that's a mine
[ __ ] i thought it was on the other side
[ __ ]
uh okay where are we going
well let's check it out anyway
no more minds i think we could
okay oh cool oh well yeah i could [ __ ]
with them
actually i think i got rid of everything
yeah i don't have any mods right now
that would be green oh it is not all
right what's in here
why is so many games about shooting i
have a theory that it's just because
aiming is satisfying it's not because we
care about violence
it's just that the literal like process
of lining something up is
fun yeah of course you can walk away
from your minds you can like
you can crouch and completely avoid them
goodbye why why pyromaniacs what
difficulties
is normal i think it's very much fallout
new vegas and space firehawk that's
exactly what this game is
okay take a quick little look around
here just for fun just for fun
little look-see oh there's a lot in
there nope take it back i take it back
we're gonna do the quest first because
it's probably going to send me back here
anyway but i won't leave until i've i've
explored it but for now
[Music]
i don't know what a cheer option is
little oxmont but uh
maybe that's not a thing that's
happening because i'm not an affiliate
or a partner which is also where you
can't sub
i chose not to i do have a partner
request sitting in my little twitch
dashboard
but i didn't want to do it
okay
avoid the mines
let's go up the hill cool with me
twitch cheers is a donation oh yeah you
can't donate on this on on my twitch
sorry friends
uh not gonna let me walk over that cool
whatever
surely there are gonna be some more
marauders right
these are pretty
the flora and fauna in this game are
pretty what is that what are those are
those humans they are
and critters again hello
jerks i suppose i'm going to have to
fight you aren't i
what if we just talked can we just
it would be so nice if we could just
have a chat i know this game does have a
a cover system i think if i remember
correctly
but uh who who uses any of that oh that
was an explosion
i'm this is so many bullets so oh hang
on can i ah
auto aim screwed me i was trying to
shoot the thing to make you explode fam
boom oh we're at ammo [ __ ] that's a
problem with the streamers i can't i
can't see ammo because i'm looking at my
own face
so that was stupid because
i'm actually looking i'm not actually
looking at the game i'm looking at the
way the stream looks
so my face is over where ammo is i'm
just move it up
oh i don't know where the stream cuts
off though let me fix my webcam settings
so that it is cut where it should be uh
no it's fine pretty much i can make that
a little more i guess bottom
100 and 50. nope that's too much
100 no that's probably about 40.
that works let's move up
okay okay that should work yes
except to the left side i could is there
nothing on the bottom left
perhaps there is not
i can do that
all right oh wait is this what i want
yes it is okay
there we go 113 not as much as i would
have liked
okay probably gonna stop streaming
pretty soon friends
thank you flynn i appreciate that
alrighty
let's do it again
okay up here we go
again it's i don't think the shooting is
the violence at all i don't even think
it
shooting satisfies instant gratification
it's the same way that all video games
where you're like aiming at something
satisfies you it's just lining things up
is satisfied wait what
you're not supposed to be here oh these
are marauders
oh they're strong dude you are strong
okay oh did it just respawn all the
enemies here
ah god i keep forgetting that i can't
reload that that got bad
that uh that was that was not good yeah
fine
did not feel good none of that felt good
no he's just coughing he's definitely
just coughing
not token just coughing
still still
all right i'm probably gonna go this
with a different weapon
anybody fired up this evening
so many people are saying this game
never really got them
yeah i really like it but um
like i said not the combat i'd probably
prefer the combat more on pc and i
did play it on pc the first time i ever
played it uh
it's like a minor inconvenience for me
to get to the interesting parts maybe i
should stop playing it on easy
okay i thought you all were further away
do i want to use this weapon
why
um no i think i do it's really my only
option
and then when i get up there i'll use
the grenade launcher
i could probably sneak past i could do
that don't have to fight him
you don't care about the characters of
the story and army but the characters in
the story are very good
like very good
yeah maybe the same for days for me days
for me rolling up took me a bit to get
into it but when i did i never put it
down might be the same for me
like i said i feel like this game is
more like a board game
oh i got a text from my stepdad let me
read that oh great he's telling me
apostle arrived
i hope that no one from my mom if you're
watching this stream stop watching
um i got that [ __ ] mother's day present
it's mother's day on sunday in australia
i think it's different in the us
all right mom you can start watching
again she's probably not realistically
all right y'all ready to [ __ ] die
i hope that this trick is one of the
explosives whoa
whoa whoa whoa hey hey hey hey i wasn't
expecting that
oh i shot you a lot that pavardi that's
my bad
let's go back up here
nope wrong gun wrong gun stuck on the
tree
wrong gun uh
and then we need to use some health
probably
what do you do
i just want to eat i guess
these are all like cool downs and [ __ ] i
just want to eat
i mean sure that sounds cool
blend of herbs oh wow plus base health
that sounds cool too
i can't eat it oh because i already have
one
it's it's a whole day um
they're all so like specked
sure that sounds cool um
i already used one of those
yeah let's use that too i should put
that stuff in those slots let me
organize that at some later date uh it's
this boy
i think this gun's dope you guys should
be way more dead than you are though
come on now like this is literally
exploding on your feet
who are you [ __ ] kidding oh well i'm
not gonna shoot you if you do that no
i'm gonna get tricked again
i'm gonna end up dying again i keep
being like look at him staring at
nothing and that's how i die
there's one left right is that it that's
it that's it
good day sirs if i could have had a
conversation with you
i would have we didn't have to go down
that route
i feel bad about that man that i killed
i didn't have to do
no have to do any of that yeah
cool cool cool cool
that's nothing
already took it maybe perhaps mayhaps
all right
uh i don't know why i'm going to the lab
i think i wanted to get the gas right
yeah
which is probably going to be in here
secret lab we're just going to walk in
i mean it does seem weird
eliminate the outlaws means there's
gonna be a lot of people i gotta kill in
here probably
it's easier than new vegas i would agree
with that i think this game is fairly
easy
i don't think it's particularly
difficult
you should make your mama called shout
out to everyone's moms
oh man
sure is pretty
hello what what ails you
death i suppose
hmm
oh i love stergy slims yeah
vodka you say okay
hello
don't kill me you hello you care to
explain what you're doing here
gotta make myself let's go outside
we don't cut off any text okay
uh i did see the sign outside anton sent
me to help
that i am name's porter bridges thank
you
i'd be glad for the help bad news is we
haven't been able to clean these outlaws
out of the lab
the good news is they haven't been able
to escape neither
that is good um actually
a bot testro said why aren't you a tier
three sub and so last channel i
literally don't even know what that
means
i have such little experience using
twitch that i
don't know what that means
who knows okay bad news is we haven't
been cleaning themselves good news is
they have been escaped
so it's a stalemate for now i reckon
they got no backup
on the other hand i'm your backup sir
you're welcome this all went haywire for
some damn reason
damn mechanicals have always been more
trouble than their worth
i do hate fighting mechanicals that is a
thing i hate i took a perk that like
makes me weaker against them i think
the garage and the front door are it
these bastards got in through the vent
system
they're not getting back out that way
without a security key card
they need to take mine or make a new one
in my office i guess
um well
why would i want to find his office who
me
or you mean the lab in general either
yeah you i'm in charge of sight safety
engineering
most days that means making sure folks
don't run in the halls
um
okay most days there ain't nothing to
hear but wind
bugs and the buildings falling slowly to
pieces i love that everyone's voice
acted
okay and it's like everyone everyone
there's so many people in this game and
they are all
it sounds kind of like john dimaggio it
kind of does
um
soap or something i don't know
toothpaste [ __ ] back they made
antibiotics
you could maybe ask doc crane what he
does all day
it's toothpaste
oh the pain ain't much but it's never
been about the bits
i like rose way really
okay well i don't know why i need to
find his office but i guess i'll ask
anyone
yeah i don't know why i'm asking that
one level down across from the cafeteria
but i locked it up and i got the only
key card
to get in they'd have to blow it we'd
hear
all right
well honestly i'm fine i don't feel like
i want to get in there
do i need to is that a thing that i
needed to do i do need his gas
but i don't think i need the security
key code fine so whatever
um all right everyone i'm going to end
the stream there and you got some food
it's dinner time and stuff uh thank you
all for joining and thank you
for the for the 30 000 followers on
twitch i appreciate that
that's real nice um sorry we had tech
issues at the start don't know where
they came from
turning everything on and off again
fixed it so that's cool
but uh yeah if you want me to sub to
lawrence
fun fact i'm not subbed to anyone on
twitch
i do love lawrence though
thank you friends yeah i'll try and
stream more often i know i keep saying
that but everything keeps breaking but i
promise i'll try
i'll do my best
when is the next one i don't know
i'll let you know when i figure it out
who knows
um yeah have a good night everyone bye